[Music]
it's hard to overstate
just how gigantic the new tesla
gigafactory project in texas is
this 1.1 billion assembly plant in the
south travis county of austin will be
tesla's fifth gigafactory in the world
with plants already set up in fremont
nevada new york and china and one
upcoming in berlin
gigafactory 5 is the most recent of
their production facilities to be
announced and it wasn't even confirmed
as a factory location
until july of 2020. elon musk has said
once it's
complete giga texas will be an
ecological paradise
with construction moving full steam
ahead it's about time we talked about
what we can expect from the new
gigafactory welcome back to our channel
before we dive in
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and ring the bell so you never miss a
video from us
2021 and 2022 are set to be hugely
eventful for tesla with their unveiling
of the iconic 4680 battery pack the
tesla semi
and the tesla cyber truck all rolling
out either in 2021 or early 2022
it makes sense that they would need a
massive facility to keep up the
construction site for gigatexas sits on
nearly 2 500 acres of land and the
facility itself
spans 4 to 5 million square feet it is
projected to complete construction by
the end of 2021
and handle an unprecedented level of
production approximately 28 times
more than the factory in nevada gigan
nevada currently has a production
capacity of 35 gigawatt hours but for
the scale tesla is eyeing they're going
to need a factory with a terawatt hour
capacity in september 2020 tesla
revealed their plans for gigatexas
and it seems to have a similar shape to
tesla's original plans for the gigan
nevada the drawings showed a large alley
splitting up a massive structure into
two parts
it seems from that time the gigafactory
has made incredible progress
the factory started construction in
january of this year during the night of
the 18th and 19th they poured concrete
foundation for the three gigapress
high-press die casting machines in the
northeast corner of the location
on the 21st the first gigapress
components arrived in crates and massive
shipping containers
on the 22nd the base frame of the first
gigapress was unboxed and craned into
position
several corners of the northeast look
almost completed workers were spotted
rolling metal tubes from spools on site
and there were several deliveries of
components
tools ducting and framing materials and
much more and while construction has
been underway
it seems one of their cyber truck
prototypes is zipping around the site
too
it was driving across the construction
zone on may 14th
this was apparently elon musk himself
driving around the site where the cyber
truck would be built
and you can't have a gigafactory without
robots robots have been arriving at the
facility with several of them being
spotted out in the open
as for the production of electric cars
the factory will have a general assembly
line set up in place
all with robots of course they will
assemble components coming in from their
other gigafactories around the world
just in time for the production of the
cybertruck scheduled for late 2021.
looks like no detail is too small for
tesla to ensure their factory delivers
on all the announcements they have made
but the giga texas is more than just a
factory parts of it will be open to the
public
and will have boardwalks streams and
hiking trails and there's your
ecological paradise
at first the facility was called the
cyber truck gigafactory since tesla
planned to produce their electric pickup
here but recently
they announced that they would use this
factory for the model y and the tesla
semi as well
they are also going to establish battery
cell production and open up that space
for public viewing
the factory is also expected to create
over 5000 jobs in the next four years
tesla is already hiring for a number of
manufacturing and engineering positions
in the facility
one recent posting is for a
manufacturing engineering manager for
leading battery production entry level
jobs start at 35
000 a year and it goes all the way up to
000 a year for more specialized
positions any of you interested
better apply fast while the fremont
factory remains the mother ship it won't
be the case for long
in may musk threatened to move tesla to
texas after local authorities refused to
let him open his factory during the
pandemic
probably after he tweeted tesla will now
move its hq and future programs to texas
nevada immediately
if we even retain fremont manufacturing
activity at all
it will depend on how tesla is treated
in the future you really don't want to
piss off the world's richest and most
influential man
the texas government welcomed tesla and
elon musk with open arms giving him
approvals and a massive tax cut of 50
million dollars
texas also doesn't collect personal
income tax while california has some of
america's highest state tax rates
texas also supported tesla's federal
request for designation as a foreign
trade zone which means they would be
exempt from paying customs on materials
used in export production
that sounds like a sweet deal and this
works out perfectly for elon musk since
his other company spacex
also has facilities in texas in two
places in fact brownsville and mcgregor
they're hiring engineers
technicians builders and essential
support they also have a high tech
factory coming up in austin for starlink
now all that remains is for musk to
actually move there currently tesla gets
its batteries manufactured by panasonic
but musk has said he is interested in
shifting that task in-house right now it
seems like the batteries will be made in
their upcoming berlin gigafactory
still soon enough it will be moved to
the texas facility some speculations say
that gigatexas will integrate tesla's
secret technology called roadrunner
roadrunner will decrease battery
production costs by a hundred dollars
per kilowatt hour in the first quarter
of 2021 tesla produced over 180
000 electric cars and delivered over 184
these numbers came in as the
construction of the 1.1 billion dollar
factory were being sped up
tesla has long been talking about
ramping up their production rate as the
company still does made to order cars
which hikes up the cost the hope is once
they enter mass production teslas will
be at least a little more affordable
one can hope right tesla's gigatexas is
set to churn out 367
000 vehicles after setup and they have a
target of 10 million cars a year they
may even start mining their own lithium
to save costs
they are already planning to build a
lithium hydroxide chemical plant to
support the factory's battery operations
it shouldn't be too difficult if they do
plan to focus gigatexas on battery
production researchers have already
identified a lithium valley that runs
between oregon and nevada it's an
abundant source of the key element
required in tesla batteries
and a mining operation has already been
set up luckily lithium is the third most
common element on the planet
so tesla 100 plans to take advantage of
that
in due course tesla will be entirely
self-reliant they might even use the
space to expand into residential energy
technology as they have been planning
for over five years now
their products include the power wall
and solar city just last month
tesla decided to make an additional
building on the site just months before
its expected completion date this is
part of tesla's bobcat project
and while there are several speculations
online nobody actually knows what it's
about
it will likely take years for the plant
to be completed but as and when sections
get finished
more and more cars will enter the
production phase initially
it will produce the tesla model y and
the tesla cyber truck will soon follow
and they have already created the
gigapress test casting for model y
when the cyber truck was first unveiled
in 2019 elon musk projected the pickup
truck to be a widely different option
from our current fossil fuel burning
trucks made by ford and general motors
but as we can see
this project won't be their sole focus
for gigatexas the factory clearly has
enough space
so tesla will be able to add many more
production lines and new models over
time
since the site is so close to spacex as
well texas might just become
a primary location for tesla we don't
have much to go on interior-wise since
it's all still underway but if elon
musk's timeline is to be believed it
won't be long before we can get a peek
inside
what do you think of this mammoth
project let us know in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video hit the like
button and check out more videos about
tech on the simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time